so heads into those end games and here
we go david the game is starting the
game has started and it's a king's pawn
open it's the italian game signified by
white bringing out his bishop on this
last move to this square and black does
the same very standard stuff and an
opening actually napoleon actually did
employ in the world championship match
against magnus carlsen he studied this
in depth that is clear however it's also
andre esopenko's favorite opening when
he has white so a really interesting
battleground now for the two players
both sides now have castle decking away
to safety and the game will slow down
for a while as both sides maneuver white
just pushing a pawn there black will
most likely do the same there we go and
uh yeah it's all about planning here all
about who can put their pieces on better
squares who can maybe break out in the
center later
most efficiently so yeah i just think
napoli actually wants to avoid any
opening battle here it's just about
understanding just about
putting those pieces on good squares
logical chess yeah definitely i mean at
this position i have to admit uh for
myself and probably uh you know even
much higher rate of players me it's so
complex to understand there's so many
subtleties and so many little poor moves
like this to stop your opponent's bishop
coming out it's a real maneuvering game
probably one of the openings which
requires uh the most slow maneuvering
out of any opening i can think of and
for someone who doesn't play these
positions it's so hard to get the right
move order right you know you've got to
play to give your pieces squares to get
your pieces in the right position but
even here this this even does this
remind me did you have this position he
did have this position yeah i had it
against ali reza faruja yeah and i think
i was commentating on that with our
friends lawrence trenton ali mortezali
and we were obviously cheering for you
thank you
and
we remember i remember some idea with
the queen coming over
you know around to the queen side but so
you're obviously a bit of an expert in
this position uh more so than me clearly
anyway uh yeah you would think that
simon but i'm the same as you despite
having played these positions with white
and with black from my entire career
since i was five six years old i still
struggle with them and the game has now
left the same path as my
my game against farouza
black's knight retreat a couple of moves
ago was the big difference there but
either way this position is still
relatively known i think
and uh both players
will still be in their homework most
likely especially andreas pence who's
playing so fast and uh choosing a
slightly rarer line but
he will have ideas
and uh yeah i remember this opening the
italian game as as we see just both
sides improve their pieces now um the
italian game when i was young i used to
play it a lot and i was criticized in
the english press uh by some very
prominent journalists they said oh it's
a beginner's opening why is he playing
this he'll never become a strong player
if he keeps playing this opening as
white and then now all the top players
in the world play it so uh
it's all about fashion payback i had
something similar actually i mean uh
this latest chess ball course i i
brought out the harry attack um i came
up with well i didn't personally come up
with an idea that i was playing like 15
years ago and people just laughed at it
and they just you know other
grandmasters said this is just absolute
rubbish but then all the top players on
the player you know the world started
playing it again so it's quite funny but
i'm amazed whoever said that about you
is just an idiot though because this is
this has been one of the main lines for
ages um so i don't know who i insulted
there but i don't really care
so but that's it's not true i mean
everyone's doing this opening now yeah
exactly and it's really caught on fire
the last four well last five years i
think 2016 kramnik started playing it a
lot with white and nan immediately every
grand master uh at the top level was
playing it with white do you think the
attraction is then because it is a slow
maneuvering game is it that you can just
play a game
and you can maneuver you're not in
trouble and you're just basically
relying on who's got the better
knowledge is that why people like it
yeah i think it's all to do with uh that
fighting index that we were talking
about it just leads to fighting chess no
matter what the type of position there's
always life left and a lot of openings
these days especially the less
maneuvering openings which are quite
direct they can lead to some full straws
here and there
the funny funny thing is like a lot of
these openings which players at home
might think are more interesting like
pawn sacrifices in the opening they're
actually a lot more duller because
they've been worked out so deeply as you
say they lead to draw so these positions
which maybe have a bad reputation are
more interesting to play because you
don't liquidate so quickly so uh yeah
it's it's maybe the way forwards and
certainly a good opening to learn if you
want to improve your your opening
understanding i don't know if you've
ever played this line of anchor i i have
played this line many years ago but i
actually gave it up because i found it
too difficult too many move orders too
many pieces on the board and i didn't
really have kind of the concrete
understanding i needed to have and i
have to say about this game
we now see a bishop trade itself for a
knight so the pogbashi has decided
to try to ruin
the pawn structure of essepenko i have
to say that it was kind of an
interesting psychological battle at the
beginning because essepenko was the
first one to launch what we call a
novelty which is a new idea but napoli
actually didn't actually seem phased at
all and just carried on blitzing out
those those moves and now we can see i
think now we can finally see that both
players are on their own can i ask
ivanka what was the first new move in
the game so the first new move was
actually picking up the queen's pawn
okay from the d6 square and moving it to
the fifth yeah so a new move but i mean
i've studied that one before i'm sure
these guys have started yeah it's one of
the top computer suggestions um so have
you studied everything i mean
some i studied superficially
i remember yesterday it was like move 25
you're like i know that knight d5 was
here and i was i was looking at the
computer and it was like knight d5 and i
started playing now he's impressing me
again so but yeah i mean you need to
work hard on chess simon your knowledge
impresses me so yeah um yeah so i mean
i'm not
familiar with this exact position but
the ideas are quite thematic here and as
ivanka mentioned the pawn structure has
changed if you look at the sea lion
black does have two doubled pawns there
so long-term weakness but as
compensation black is relatively active
i'm especially liking the black bishop
right now which is unrivalled we saw a
trade of some bishops one of the black
knights disappeared but black's bishop
is going to look over at that left side
of the board at a weak white
white pawn for a long long time so
i would say this position
both sides have reasons to be happy but
uh that is only going to be good for us
it's going to be a real clash of styles
clash of uh
imbalances because especially while the
nights the two nights against the bishop
and knight combo exists
there's going to be life left i have to
say normally i like the double knight
combination but in this particular
situation i just like you highlighted i
like the power of the light squared
bishop it's going to be something that
might
come back to haunt white especially if
the battle develops onto who controls
the open d-line
yeah and i guess that's why napoli has
just jumped in with the white knight
we've talked about the square the f5
square that's an f5 or thrive and now
black has a difficult choice you want to
keep your bishop ideally especially if
you have ambitious intentions in this
game as black but then again
can you really let that white knight
survive
right we'll have some attacking chances
we talked about rook swinging across the
board yesterday quite a lot and white's
rook on the third rank if you leave that
knight alive if you don't capture it if
you move the black queen i was about to
say then white's rook at some point
later might swing across on the third
rank towards the black king so a bit of
a risky decision there by essepenko but
it shows that he's not scared if he took
that white knight i think he would have
been the one fighting for the draw now
very healthy position for black as long
as he takes care of his king and do you
think david that jessie panko
needs to decide this in the rapid
portion of this semifinal do you think
gian will be a big favorite in thai
breaks yeah um i mean esopenko he's a
great player we've seen him progress so
much especially over the last 12 months
or so
but at blitz he's far less experienced
than the pontiac napoleon is one of the
real elite few in blitz and i actually
played i sepenko myself a few months ago
in blitz and
compared to playing against the top guys
he's not quite there yet
so yeah i think if the match goes to
blitz napoli actually will be an even
bigger favorite than he is right now in
the rapids and i actually think right
there we're getting an answer to
something we've been a little bit
curious about because as he panko he's
always so fidgety uh a lot of energy and
we've seen him sip something from a cop
and i think we could there see that that
is coffee so maybe that is why he is
a little bit full of energy while
playing these games he's playing late in
the night yeah that's true so i imagine
he needs some
some caffeine to get him going
because it's quite well i would find it
very very difficult but i know a lot of
chess players are creatures of the night
and they like to stay up until the early
hours and estepenga actually said it
himself he's a keen follower of football
so he often stays up late to watch
those football matches but you know i
think he might be an arsenal fan
yeah i think so i've seen him wear an
arsenal t-shirt okay yeah i can actually
confirm i talked to him on the tata
steel and he said arsenal and mostly
because of the great archavin great
russian football player
can't be good at everything then can you
poor taste so um i've actually played
football with him myself i must say um
in the isle of man 2019 and he's very
good at your heart he's tricky he's got
long legs so he's it's hard to tackle
but uh
yeah and jan's wearing his lucky t-shirt
again we see yeah which
has done so well for him so far what is
it fifth day in a row now
yeah yes yes
lucky t-shirt maybe he's got five of
them yeah
yeah that could be
you could wash them
yeah yeah you could do him i don't we've
learned the chess players they love
their coffee as we see with asapengo but
they're also superstitious if things are
going well which they have been for yan
then why change things and uh
very impressive so far he though as
white i was about to say
um he's been thinking quite a long time
we're not used to that from jan normally
he's playing instantly the one putting
the opponent under pressure on the clock
this time rolls have reversed white is
lower on the clock but this last move
simon you must like it it's going on the
attack with white i love this yeah i
mean it's always great seeing yam play
because he is a very aggressive player
at heart i mean he's basically a bit of
a hacker and uh you know he's like a
young kasparov
in in many ways with with his
expressions a lot of the time he's you
know similar to kasparov he shows his
emotions which gives us a lot of drama
but the way he plays he sees a king he
goes for the king and now that rook may
well come over and join the attack and
if you can get his queen also pointing
towards what could be a hook
we call this pawn in front of the black
king
a possible hook it's a possible target
and it was a book called the art of
attack where uh the the author of this
book basically wrote a lot about having
a focal point in in your opponent's
position you've got to aim for when
attacking and i did chess ball course in
this book so i know it well and it
really is finding a point where you can
get into your opponent's position and uh
that pawn there which he's now lining up
against so you can see the plan is
coming together is uh where he's aiming
for so it's a good bit of advice there
just look for a focal point and try to
line your pieces up to start targeting
uh that point and already here is it's a
little bit scary isn't it uh for sap co
it's very scary yeah very scary even
yeah yeah yeah i kind of don't think
it's that scary the reason why i'm going
to say it's not that scary because it's
really obvious what it's going to do
yeah i mean it's obvious that like you
know dave is highlighting that h6 pawn
is going to be under fire so therefore
you can take
some action against that
and then concentrate your action
you know back to the middle of the board
where black is superior yeah so this is
a really instructive move by esopenko
dropping the queen back defending the
pawn next to it but also if white's
rooks uh swings across now the pawn can
simply step forward and look at this
indirectly the queen was actually
defending this pawn all along uh now the
queen defends it the king defends it
it's defended twice that means white
doesn't have the
firepower to go and capture this pawn
it's still a bit scary because white has
four attackers these two knights plus a
rook plus a queen and black only really
has three defenders right now um the
queen king and bishop but it looks like
it's sufficient black's pawn structure
is solid enough so uh as ivanka
mentioned black is planning to just
defend for the next few moves with this
queen retreat but then at the right
moment start a counter-attack maybe
including against horn maybe jumping
forward with the black knight and
if white's attack fizzles out if the
fire stops burning then yeah maybe
napoli actually he's committed all of
his pieces to the wrong side of the
board so uh yeah right now napoli
actually needs to back up his previous
moves with some kind of substance with
some kind of real attack
it's pencil definitely playing a lot
faster than john so far this game with
the black pieces is that surprising him
in in any way
yeah i mean it must be part of his
strategy jan can't be used to that right
and the opponent being quicker than him
not many people in the world are quicker
than yanukoneshi so uh yeah surprising
and also esopenko
he's had a lot of decisive results in
this tournament but his clock usage has
been a bit up and down i remember him
being in time trouble in a couple of
games
so maybe it's just part of his strategy
and meanwhile one move white's pawn
stepping forward that pawn cannot be
captured because black's bishop has to
stay defending the black knight yeah i'm
actually incredibly surprised by this
move because yes it's dynamic but it
does concede a really important square
in the middle of the board and i'm
looking at that d4 square i'm thinking
if a rook could find its way down even
better it would be a knight
and i can just see that it will be an
extra benefit that black has in this
position so control of the d line a
great uh light squared bishop
um i'm a little bit concerned for napoli
actually that unless he does something
there on the right
he might be burning his bridges yeah
this knight retreat not a good sign if
you're retreating pieces the white
knights are a bit dominated right now
they're gonna have to keep retreating
simon a fan of that last move no i mean
i i think as soon as you start playing
news like this it's gone wrong i mean i
was getting obviously quite excited
because i love uh these attacking ideas
but this this queen retreating move that
black played uh was a fantastic move and
it seems just to have stopped all the
white's counter play and you can often
find that these attacks are very
premature
and they they don't work out very well
and as soon as you start going backwards
you've just lost like five tempo and um
we we can see here that with this last
move black's starting to put pressure on
on white's queen side and
i'm thinking yeah um this is this is
certainly going so pienko's way at the
moment um ivanka pointed out the square
in the middle of the board which which
seems like a long a long-term target as
well which only black come into black's
double pawns
look pretty useful because they they
cover uh some central squares as well so
um obviously a lot to play for here
there's loads of pieces on the board but
um black espnko must be happy with the
way it's gone and with the time
advantage he he still has yeah not just
the time advantage he's about to win a
pawn and he does win a pawn uh that pawn
couldn't actually be protected if we
just rewind a couple moves to show why
uh the black knight jumping forward this
pawn there's no way to defend it if you
march it forward firstly it can get
captured by the black queen but black's
knight is going to jump in with a fork a
double attack and uh if you try to
protect it with your own pawn then after
a trade we see that white can no longer
capture with this pawn because there's a
pin along this a-line so that pawn was
doomed and napoli actually had to move
out of the way of a potential night fork
with his queen and now after knight
takes pawn uh he simply steps back with
his rook so black is actually a whole
porn up and
yes it's not maybe the best pawn in the
world the most attractive pawn in the
world but somehow if you can keep it
alive and as you guys mentioned if you
can use this central outpost for a black
rook or if you can get the black rooks
to open lines without allowing white any
counter play then black is doing great
so right now a pawn up from essepenko
and good chances to convert it
yeah all right well uh we did see the
fighting chess index foreign
above 70 right and uh we did look at
that he he's only played what was it
five draws so far in the tournament in
what
19 games or something like that yeah i
mean that's incredible yeah nearly never
see those stats at the top level and
especially in the prelims only three
draws yeah he was still up there in the
top half so yeah fighting player and we
saw his determination uh to win games he
was always fighting it out to the bitter
end very rarely chickening out with a
draw or playing the safe moves always
playing the most ambitious moves
so yeah we'd like to see that definitely
we do like to see that and the audience
really does appreciate the fighting
chess and because we're just sticking to
the chest today we're asking everyone
just to tweet us their chess comments
and chess
ideas moves and we will ask
our experts and we will feature them on
the show yeah so you can do all this via
the hashtag chesschamps definitely would
be very interesting to have some move
suggestions that we could look into deep
dive a little bit with analysis
into some of your suggestions
okay meanwhile the black one of the
black rooks does find an open file
hitting white pawns over there those
loose white queen side pawns and uh
white had to match one of the pawns up
hitting the black knight and no
exchanges interesting move there from
essepenko
i must admit i would have struggled to
find a move like that one putting the
knight on the edge of the board but
maybe there are some specific ideas
uh white's queen
can go and grab a pawn back now maybe
i don't think the white queen is going
to go and capture the black central pawn
because the black knight might jump in
with a night fork white's rooks are
actually uh within range now of the
black knight so you have to be a bit
careful
but white's queen can just kind of zoom
up and capture one of the two black
doubled pawns i'm wondering whether
essepenko maybe just is he
maybe i mean i just said he was playing
the most ambitious moves in every
position but
is he maybe just letting the advantage
slip a bit
and uh giving back the pawns now
in some ways it's a nice move though
because we pointed out the square in the
middle of the board and uh the black
knight is is just trying to re-route uh
um in into that lovely square so if that
knight can it just takes two moves get
right into the center um white could be
in trouble but white's played the most
critical move he's taking that pawn on
c6 so what is uh andre's
what is his idea here is he going to
take the pawn on b3 try to win it back
or is he going to potentially keep keep
maneuvering that knight
around okay queen d6 that's interesting
just trying to go for exchange of queens
still looks really horrible for white
this to me because those brooks the
black rooks are just uh it's a bit like
the benko opening um if anyone can it
knows that opening where you get all
this play
yeah named after um mr benko powell
benko yeah okay
good thing i was benco here and um yeah
it's a really interesting opening where
you give up a pawn to get these open
lines and um also look at these nights
they're not contributing at all the
action's starting to move over towards
this side of the board as you point out
simon but white's knights they're far
away
and also if we remember the aimchest
stats that uh skill was showing us end
games yeah essepenko is ruthless i think
he had 80 something percent win rate in
end games once the queen's come off um
so now the queen exchange might happen
at some point white bringing the rook
across to support the white queen this
was important because if white had taken
on black's terms then suddenly black's
pawns connect to each other but also big
threats firstly of winning a pawn with
pawn takes pawn but also of the knight
jumping in to attack the two white rooks
at the same time so a really important
move there from jana pognishi defending
his queen and now
this other plan that you guys have
mentioned isapenko he's kind of finding
all the plans and wrapping them together
and putting them all
into one because he's dropped this
knight back and now it's about to land
in the center of the board where it will
cause some real nuisance so is this a
situation where the black knight and the
black bishop are uh stronger than the
two white knights together
yes yes nice on the rim of dim yeah and
that's on the edge and
in light of the plan that david
highlighted of jumping the black knight
to the center i would be very very
tempted to just pick up my knight that's
sitting on the edge the white knight
move up to the f3 square
yeah that would be one move that i would
consider and then or maybe i would try
to kind of like do a variation of that
maybe go pawn takes pawn first you know
because i don't want to give up material
and uh
see what happens then
and now okay the knight has returned
to the f3 square this is very important
because the knight is covering that that
square and also maybe maybe in the right
circumstance there's going to be some
knight takes
pawn in the middle of the board
yeah the knight also eyeing up this guy
so meanwhile we have seen a trade over
here and the question is can black just
be greedy and he has
gone for it greed is sometimes good and
bishop takes pawn black is a clear pawn
up i don't see any way for white to win
the pawn back this pawn now
another plus behind black's knight
retreat is that it does defend this
slightly weak pawn this isolated pawn
and uh yeah these two white knights
still struggling to get in the game
napoleon retreats his queen he's not out
of this one because if he wins one of
these two pawns back he will have a
level position but it's certainly white
fighting for his life
this queen retreat does at least hit the
black pawn in the center
and uh black has to find a way to keep
these two pawns alive and if he does i
think he's a big favourite to win the
end game wow well just a reminder about
the format the semi-final matches are
played in one day four rapid games to
decide the winner and if they are tied
then they head straight to tie breaks
with two blitz games and if it's still
tied then we have armageddon and in each
match they have 15 minutes
in between each games
uh so hopefully there's going to be
chess going on all day and we're going
to try to show and follow as many games
and moves as possible in both of these
matches and in the court finals
yesterday we didn't actually have one
single tie break
so let's see if that's going to happen
today that was surprising four matches
no tie breaks
yeah we rarely saw that happen last
season on the tour right yeah it was
just it seems to be tie breaks in every
match yeah
yeah it feels like we will get them at
some point either in the semi-finals
today or maybe even the final because
these players the last four are all so
good yeah it's gonna be so close
yeah i think this is quite instructive
the way this game's gone wrong actually
for yan uh and this is kind of
a typical mistake that i see a lot of
players actually do especially uh you
know club players that kind of standard
where they they they take the aggressive
onslaught against their opponents king
and i was again myself quite excited
about that and as ivanka pointed out
hanging a bit this is really easy to
defend against and you do these
aggressive moves but uh you just you
haven't really worked out your
opponent's best defense and you come
backwards you lose all this time you
lose the initiative and you just have a
bad position so you've really got to
attack from from a position of strength
and make sure uh you don't get forced
back and it's artificial attacking uh is
is just a classical mistake that a lot
of people do they they attack because
they think it's gonna work but they
haven't calculated it and they just end
up going home again and uh that's that's
certainly what's happened in this game
here yeah i remember one of my friends
uh on that subject was had this little
motif he goes um
you shouldn't impose your will on the
board you need to be objective you need
to do what needs to be done so if the
position demands that you're boring you
know then so be it
put your boring hat on and make those
slow like sensible moves if the position
demands that you should initiate chaos
then again
you need to do that you need to put that
hat on and go hey totally agree let's uh
initiate that i think you've got to be
objective rather subjective so even if
you're a really aggressive person and
and you want to take over things and you
know take over the space in the area
yeah you should you should avoid doing
that and
that's something that's gone wrong here
i think you know he had to be more
objective about his chances and and do a
slower approach yeah fair play to jan
though
he does uh have a more universal streak
to his play than he used to and
he doesn't seem too unhappy yes white is
on the defensive white is just a pawn
down hence the evaluation bar but he
will try and defend and a really sneaky
move there from esopenko we got to say
black bringing the rook the whole way
down there was a trap there if white got
tempted to take that black rook then the
white queen would have lost her defender
and the white queen would have fallen so
um also a trap maybe we can show this on
the board because it is such a sneaky
move but uh if we just rewind two moves
back black bringing this rook down uh if
you take the rook as mentioned the queen
falls and if you take the black queen
thinking okay black is just going to
recapture no there's what we call an
intermediate move rook takes rook is a
check and next move black wins the queen
having pocketed a rook in the process so
uh instead we saw nepomiacci not fall
for that and here he just gets his king
out the way so the queen and rook keep
their connection and now we do see a
rook trade and uh with the exchanges
who do we think that's going to help
probably black yeah i think science life
the only danger i can see in black's
position is his pawn structure on the
king side so uh black's pawns have sort
of moved a little bit up the boards
leaving his seventh rank weak so if
somehow white can uh bring his rook down
to where david's showing there on the
board um the king could be it's a little
bit soft a little bit softer than it
would like to be so uh uh but of that it
seems like a fairly straightforward pawn
uh porn advantage for uh espnko here and
he's pushing that pawn past pawns
should be pushed reinforcing control
over that all-important d4 square
because you know the move that i would
have loved to have played um just now
would have been actually to move my rook
to the d-line challenge the black queen
but unfortunately
with black's last move the knight can
just sit herself there in the middle
become that
famous octo knight and there's no
getting rid of that knight
yeah if you ever try and trade it off it
just gets replaced by a very strong pawn
and these two together just going to
hold each other's hand and uh march down
the board these pawns will win the game
for black and too strong yeah so so
obviously like
the podiatry is is worse and i'm just
wondering whether it's the time is now
to kind of initiate like swindle mode
like you know and by that i mean you
just play a tricky move try to
do something mysterious on the right
side i think he's going to try that
ivanka because now he's hit the black
bishop but if black plays maybe the most
obvious move in the position bringing
the knight in
defending the bishop
then he has to try something against the
black king because if he doesn't he's
just going to get squashed this pawn is
going to start marching down the board
i don't really see any way out for white
so maybe it is time to go back to plan a
uh he abandoned this plan long ago but
something to do with the black king
whether that's bringing the knight back
to the side and trying to create some
sacrifice open things up or whether
that's pushing harry the h-born forward
at some point it feels like he has to do
something i thought it was a nice nice
trick in the position before that well i
don't think it will work because
obviously espnko is incredibly strong
player but if you'd have gone h4 h5
um you want to you have some queen h6
stupid ideas of you know in some random
position but h4h5 would be a lovely
maneuver uh that white could play but i
guess black just stops
that pawn in his tracks by uh meeting
meeting that h moving by blocking it
straight away and i don't see really how
that would help
the position at all yeah just to show
your idea there's some
there's some night forks uh night
jumping in sometimes you can think about
sacrifice and then the knight jumping in
with the check
but uh as you mentioned
this h pawn push will be blocked by
black's h pawn as well but i quite like
that h pawn because it does give as you
mentioned simon earlier a hook
that the white knight sitting on g3
which isn't doing anything let's face it
gives it something to kind of maybe bite
on in the future
and then then i'm like thinking well
what can white do to try to defend this
the
the knight isn't working so then the
knight on f3 is not working so maybe
that can be
moved around
find a better square yeah that's exactly
what i was thinking david yeah
i mean interesting position jan instead
lifted his rook up the board so maybe
he's just keeping these in mind for
later and i'm surprised to see esapenko
think maybe he's just choosing between
two very attractive moves he can bring
his knight to the center as i mentioned
earlier or he can just push this pawn
forward and actually the more i think
about it maybe this one first is the
most effective because it's simply
marching down the board it's going to
march even further and then the queen
will come and uh eliminate white's queen
as a blockader and uh yeah this one so
close to promotion
maybe white just has to step this knight
back to blockade it because if you let
it march on it's just gonna win the game
for black i mean if i if i was white
after c4 i'd just i'd just flick in
knight h4 and i would just go for um
the desperado attack i mean he's gone c4
so we might see this and it's like one
of those situations where if you don't
do something drastic um then you're
gonna lose so so you have to do
something which you wouldn't normally do
you know um you're gonna lose your
opponent's coming into your territory
you need to take some action now and
moving that knight over there well okay
you you you might be a sacrifice on g6
bring the other knight in yeah but he's
got more defensive okay
i like your idea
if it's going wrong but maybe maybe this
is actually
maybe this is
it's a little bit annoying for black but
yeah it's annoying but it's a passive
approach it's defensive
even if white just plants a knight on
this square black will not actually
trade the knights and um i wouldn't be
surprised to see black just plonk his
knight in the center of the board anyway
at some point also you can never take it
now because the queen will open up
towards the white king
white is just going to be completely
stuck and black at the right moment will
bring the rook into the game
still the black king will be a bit weak
but
black is definitely in charge yeah and
uh also
i'm really glad that you point out the
rook moving to the open a line because
white dis does have ambitions in putting
the queen there
but it doesn't have the time
just no just black has full control yeah
but i don't know how black's going to
deal with his pawn um after the the
knights move now uh in the game he's
he's got at least white's got this uh
direct fret here um so what what is
black doing here actually oh okay sorry
he would drop back with the other night
yeah yeah and
because you're threatening to win the
pawn in two different ways here so it is
a direct threat at least so um what can
you can you still put your knight in the
center and just kind of say hey
got a little pin
if you capture that porn but let's see
if i can take it because the rook can
back up my knight as well uh potentially
um so is this is this yeah this would be
really interesting because i guess you
guys want to bring the queen here
pinning the white knight the white
knight can't move
and if you defend it as simon mentions
then maybe black can reinstate the pin
and so much pressure everything
happening now on the sea line
i mean it's still very very messy but it
does look like black might win a piece
at least temporarily yeah some tricks
here maybe but uh this is what andre
esopenko is calculating right now in the
current position can he just sacrifice a
pawn back to tie up white's pieces but
instead he plays the safe approach oh
well
i say safe but you are abandoning your
king you're at least keeping your pawn
safe next to the queen the problem is
now you've got to be very very careful
for example after 96 bishop at the
moment it's fine because the white queen
can't jump in with a check because the
black knight covers this square but if
white breaks through to the seventh rank
now for example if the rook somehow gets
in it's going to be deadly
so this one could still turn around
black a pawn up and probably
with an advantage but white has some
hope if he can get to the black king and
the bar did react to ezipenko's last
move down to 0.9 advantage for him
sorry in the other game uh the bar has
jumped up four magnus crossing looking
good for the norwegian in the first game
in that semi-final match
yeah and uh whilst we're waiting for
napoliashi to come up with a move in
this difficult position uh rainey santos
does ask us a question
he they ask after over the board games
i've noticed some players rearranging
the pieces to their original positions
except the kings
what does this mean
which is except the kings which is left
in the center of the board what is the
background on this practice
that's a good question um it's just a
practical thing um normally when players
place the kings in the middle of the
board it's to show uh the result of the
game so for example if the white king is
on the light square or if both kings are
on the white squares it means white one
if both of the kings are on the dark
squares it means black one if the kings
are opposite each other it means a draw
and uh actually when we play chess
nowadays
on electronic boards when it's broadcast
live on the internet the moves
automatically transmit but there's no
way to show the results so that's how we
do it we show the result by putting the
kings in the middle and also we
sometimes leave the kings there just to
show our kind of other competitors what
the result was in the game
because for example you might be
fighting for first place in the
tournament and you look over and you
don't know what result happened yeah so
just looking at the kings you know what
result went on in that game and
that might influence your own decisions
in your own game very clever actually
yeah but but we don't do that in online
chess obviously uh
here it's just clicking a button
basically yeah yeah the results are
shown quite prominently yeah when it
comes to online chess and over the board
chess
not quite the same yeah so it's
especially useful in team events so yeah
of course yeah yeah did you hear that
story at the british championships going
back like
i don't know a long long time ago well
before we were born but there was a
disgruntled player and um he snuck
apparently into the tournament hall and
he he glued all the kings to the chest
sorry sorry simon just a lot of movement
on essepenko what's happening david i
don't know i think he feels there's a
win in the position he's just getting
very very excited there as you can see
shaking back and forth it's not because
he thinks he's blundered it's his move
now but maybe he thinks there's
something strong in the position i don't
see it immediately yet
maybe it involves pushing this black
pawn forward maybe involves bringing the
black knight to the center of the board
but
he
feels something in the position his
instincts are tingling his spidey senses
as i sometimes say and uh yeah he's
i can't wait to see what he has in store
because he clearly has something in mind
and now he's into calculation mode you
see how he's bobbing up and down he's
going okay this move then this move then
this move they're shaking his head he's
like oh maybe it's not so clear and now
he played the safety first move so
with two minutes left on the clock look
at this esepenco he is uh feeling the
nerves definitely heating up now and
after the knight takes bishop the pawn
recaptures the knight as we mentioned
white's queen cannot go up and checkmate
the black king yet
but uh still that black king not feeling
entirely safe
so yeah i mean this is getting really
double-edged let's ignore the evaluation
bar for now which thinks black is
completely winning because it's not that
simple black's king is going to come
under some kind of attack isn't he just
going to queen this people yeah i mean
just i don't see anything white can do
you can bring your queen in with a
checkup at some point but uh you're not
going to do anything anxious with the
black is not going to let you
wow it's a problem isn't it i said if
you try to get your rook in now um you
have to try and get to the black king
because that b pawn is just going bang
bang queen thank you very much yeah um
but if you try that maybe i can just
block with the knight i mean okay let's
try and keep an eye on the players as we
show this uh but right now as mentioned
the queen coming up right
well i thought maybe you swing the rook
over are you swinging the rook over this
way yeah then i just block with the
knight in the center where i want to put
my knight okay and if your queen comes
in i don't think i'm too worried because
my queen can always come back and it's
just one check because where are you
going with the black king
um
i would be a bit worried here simon i
don't know just go back
to the corner i guess uh
anyways so this square and maybe now i'm
jumping in with the knight hitting this
pawn threatening some checkmates okay we
have to change our minds then not that
question
i think corn takes night this is going
to end in queen f8 or something seems uh
in this position and then you bring the
trophy maybe take this
one oh nicely check there's tricks in
the position now black's queen will get
deflected away from the protection of
its rook this would be a check and
suddenly things turn around so white has
to black has to be really careful um for
example after this rook move you
mentioned maybe the idea is to just lift
this rook up first
uh just to guard the seventh rank and
then if the queen jumps in the whole way
now you block and now at least this rook
can't come in but then again there's
going to be checks still tricks yeah
still tricks uh for example just to show
the check and then the rook swinging
across this way it got blocked uh going
up the board so now it comes across the
board
no problem actually right now
calculating all of these possible moves
i think in the current position he's
looking at two moves either bringing his
queen up the board to try and go for
this pawn or okay the move you suggested
has been played this rook across and
it's tricky for black
still some hard work to be done to win
this game the evaluation bar says okay
it's winning for black as you guys
mentioned this pawn is just going to
make a new queen and win the game but
first you have to defend
so if you try the same line but put your
king in the corner that's probably a lot
safer yeah so i need to block your rook
out definitely because
uh i gotta try to keep out your pieces
but yeah it's much more dangerous than i
thought um with this with this very
clever night jump that white's got but i
guess i have to go in the corner then so
i can i can try going this way but if
you're going to the corner maybe the
queen
can
swing across
okay
you're going to find out the answer i
see now this pawn under attack this pawn
under attack it's not entirely clear
look at the bar exactly from a human
point of view with two minutes left on
the clock you're the one being attacked
it's not easy no no no
with computer precision black is winning
but these guys aren't computers these
guys are humans he's got under two
minutes to to find the right solution as
well after this so my suspicion is that
the king the black king has to accept
that maybe it's going to go on a run
yeah and find solace yeah yeah yeah no
one no one wants to be involved in a
king run because uh basically
you're walking a tight right one mistake
and that's it you could be checkmated i
mean it's probably i guess in that last
line i mean there's ways you can bring
your black queen back to defend and
there should be some way to do it but
it's dangerous and we're going to find
out yeah we're going to find out there's
three sensible moves oh which way is he
going with the king he's put his king on
the
bad square but now the knight comes in
and white is completely winning now this
night move sacrificing the knight wins
for napomniachi because after pawn takes
knight this is just gonna end in
checkmate the rook's swinging across
this way and will the players react i
don't think they've spotted this this is
exactly what we showed a few moments ago
yeah if the pawn doesn't capture the
knight if the queen drops back then the
knight sacrifices itself wow and
if you can get it
yeah and he's played it but what about
andre's reaction here it's incredible as
he is he must now realize hang on him
he's yeah he's going to react let's look
at the players faces napoli actually
suddenly looking much happier
yeah
and it's all been in vain
yeah gosh that's how quickly things can
change just one wrong move especially
when your king is open when there's no
defensive pieces around your king
i mean things will change 360 if you
just take your eye off the ball for one
move that's what he did and
poor guy head in his hands now
it's too late as well there's no turning
back checkmate is threatened which queen
is going to swing across black is going
to have to give up some material to try
and at least at least he can feel better
after this game knowing that i fell for
the same trick
that's not gonna make him feel better
obviously i'm just saying that'll make
him feel a lot worse but um yeah it's uh
it's incredible actually how this has
turned on this move yeah yeah taking
under one minute
that's why you have to be so careful
when it comes to kingston
also psychologically he's been in
control as black the whole game he's had
the advantage the whole game and just
won this the worst worst way to lose
when you're actually being controlling
the game you played a really nice game
you've been out playing your opponent
which she has done look at him yeah and
and you suddenly lose that is the worst
way to lose it's it's a lot it's a lot
less painful if you've been outplayed
most of the game because like you never
thought you had a chance but when you
get your expectance up to win and
suddenly bang you've lost something it
is really heart-wrenching
and it's it's a horrible feeling and 20
seconds for esapenko magnus carlson has
won the first game against artemyev
and this one is is it over for isabenko
or can he still save a draw it's not
over yet still some chances i quite like
his last move with the black queen um it
took me a while to spot that one as well
because now white's queen cannot swing
across the black queen keeps the seventh
rank guarded but white can just step
back with the queen as i was going to
say and take this pawn and look at this
lined up against the black king now on
this diagonal there's some deadly
discovered checks if the white knight
moves out of the way and also black's
knight in the middle of the board is
hanging so this one i think jan's got it
in the bag uh just needs to be a bit
accurate over these next few turns the
black knight retreating now okay
esopenko he's fighting he is a fight as
we saw in the chess index and he's
trying his best he's destabilizing the
white queen now the white queen can
maybe just take a step back on the
diagonal and start attacking some of
these black pawns that are undefended
near the black king
it's uh still difficult white is
completely winning now but some accuracy
is needed we've seen one turn around
yan we'll try and make sure we don't see
another one
wow
you got a feel for andreas panko look at
him shaking his head just first so
frustrated
that
he's maybe threw it away and and the
clock is ticking so fast for him as well
yeah it always ticks faster when your
heart is beating when there's been a big
turn around being a big blunder
somehow the seconds just tick away
instantly and uh this last queen move
does threaten checkmate in two moves
with the queen going and taking a pawn
in front of the black king so black has
to stop that black blocks and attacks
the white queen in the process
so the queen steps forward and now
there's a big threat in the position
white actually just wants to bring the
rook across and capture black's
dangerous pawn on this left side
deflecting away the black queen because
then the white queen will sneak in with
a checkmate black's queen is the only
defender so it has to stay on the
seventh rank
there was a sneaky check white blocks
and another threat is the other major
threat just bring the third piece into
the attack and the queen and knight
combine so well when attacking but if
you can get the rook to the seventh rank
which i think is is his next move it's
it's over it is over i mean no way to
stop it at all yeah
yeah the tragedy is you can't even give
up your queen for material banking on
the past pawn
instead yeah this is the best shot but
now the rook can certainly try to get in
somewhere there's even the flashy move
here i bring that down to the sixth rank
uh where the queen might better take it
just you're threatening to capture the
knight that could be the killer blow
actually here you could also bring it to
the seventh rank that would cross the
queen
i think there's a few moves that win
here but uh
okay
jan still needs to show some accuracy
the evaluation bar says a crazy number
for white and it is winning for white
but one wrong move and that black pawn
does make a new queen so um jan with two
minutes left needs to find a move i
think one of those two rook moves you
could even just move the rook across one
square to hit the black queen um yeah
that's just anything oh david
just moved the rook cold blooded yeah so
and trying to
destabilize the black queen or hit it or
deflect it away because the black queen
is the only defender of the black king
right now
he's got one minute 40 and espionco has
only got 11 seconds as well so he might
as well use his time here um just to
find the the best way to finish it off i
guess yeah i think the best one is just
move the white rook across one square
when the
okay he does this when the black queen
moves i'm expecting it to move it still
needs to protect the knight in the
center then you can take black's pawn
and uh
can you not win the queen as well
okay stepping back how are you oh no not
stepping back or stepping forward to the
d6 square sorry
uh which piece
i was just gonna okay okay okay very
complicated stuff there and there we see
the evaluation bar not liking what jan's
done actually yeah black found the only
move we see the stockfish moves there
three suggestions black found the only
move to keep the game alive and uh now
the black rook has come across them
it's a turnaround look at this
counter-attack and the computer confirms
incredible black is alive what a move um
it's still tricky for black but asepenko
finding the only defense with he had
seven seconds on his clock would you
have found that i think i would have
struggled and uh white's queen was under
fire black's queen was under fire but a
queen trade would actually help black
whose pawn on the left side would have
run through
and uh won the game so
suddenly all three results are possible
again and uh yan wasting a move he
brought his rook up his rook goes up
again and now reacting defending kind of
seems like a draw is probably the fair
result now after they they found their
chances get some peace on the board take
the draw and after knight d7
well there's probably a chance it could
be a draw here actually i i mean but
well i don't know i don't know
we mustn't forget that black has a big
big killer there on on b3 but they both
had chances here
and just great defense there from sap
encoder to stay in the game yep and uh
right now if the rooks come off the
board white is still a pawn up black's
king is still weak but it's all about
that black pawn on the left side of the
board two squares away from promoting
kenny when can he move it
he's going to hope soon he's been
stopped removing it for the last 10 or
so moves
but
as soon as white starts running out of
threats which he's about to then that
black pawn is going to motor forward and
sprint towards becoming a new queen um
jan as white has stopped that from
happening black's pawn running by
creating threats every single move like
he's defended estepanko what does white
actually play here because i mean you
really don't want to swap the rooks off
because
um well you might have to go into an
ending actually but could you do that i
don't know could that be the fail safe
like swap everything off and then let
the white knight okay he has the
question was what else and look at this
last move by esmenko giving up the black
knight but if white's queen goes and
captures that knight then the black
queen jumps forward with a check
taking that white pawn on the second
rank and white has no chance of winning
that game and if you take the queens off
and i mean that that's very risky
because that b pawn is so strong but you
can try queen takes queen and bring your
knight back i think that's the only way
to try and win the game but yeah it
looks the b pawn i think is just too far
advanced so maybe this will maybe this
will actually now just peter out so yeah
if the queens do come off well okay okay
the draw is about to happen black giving
up a knight but now the white king
cannot escape the checks so black's
queen can just continue checking forever
and look at this the evaluation bar
thinks maybe black has an advantage
really
i don't believe that i think queen and
it's so strong in such such positions i
mean you could maybe try b2
but can you your king surely can't run
away out of this well okay he goes for
the draw
no way out for the white king both sides
shaking their head yeah fair result in
the end but what a fight yeah that was a
really good fight yeah what a start to
this semi-final match a draw between
jana pognati and andre essipanko in the
first game their second game will start
in 15 minutes but the second game
between magnus carlsen and vladislav
artemia